Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning
fucking podcast for Monday,
Monday, uh, March 26th. Um, I just
had the breakfast of champions.
People.
I had a fucking,
I had an egg always g a G.
Hey lady.
What you make Dag, take it easy.
I hate a fucking egg over easy.
I had a week English muffin
sliced in half, so it's only one,
but it counts as two. And then I finished
it off with a slice of cheesecake.
So I got salt and sugar pumping
through my fucking veins.
In other words,
I am going to go like a madman for about
eight minutes and then I'm going to
crash me in. I don't feel
like doing it anymore, man.
Um, let's talk about, let's talk about
what else we going to talk about. Bill,
let's talk about your fucking life.
I got a Goddamn crow.
This is three weeks in a row
with the fucking animals first.
The squirrels last week. It was a
moth. This week we got it. We got it.
I got a CHRO.
I don't know if that built the fucking
nest far as I know crows don't have ness.
Am I wrong here? As far as my, my, uh,
observance of birds to
crows or the drifters,
they just showed us like show up like
Clint Eastwood used to in those cowboy
movies and then all the
other birds fucking scatter.
And then they sit there with that
little fucking hand rolled cigar
bandanna around their fucking burden neck.
Anyways,
I guess the same way nobody knew that
there was a mafia until Robert Kennedy
told everybody that there was a mob.
Um,
I finally discovered the crows actually
have never thought they just floated
around having one night
stands with sparrows,
but evidently they have a fucking nest
or this crow loves the tree right outside
my window because every morning at
like six 30 now there's fucking crow.
I don't know what it's doing.
I'm sound asleep. Right?
I'm getting my beauty sleep.
I'm a fucking ginger, right? My
face is gonna crack up unless it,
unless I make sure I get eight hours
dunk my face and lotion every day.
But I don't do that look like
I was fishing for lobsters. Um,
so every morning this fucking
crow is outside my window.
Just gone.
Like for fuck,
I want to throw,
I want to get up and it just
fucking throw my iPhone at it.
That's what I want to do.
But I'm so fucking tired I can't move.
So I just lay there and um,
I dreamed that I'm doing it,
that I walk up to the
window and I lifted it up.
Am I dream of wearing a wife beater?
You know,
cause anytime you're mad and you want
to yell out your window, you have to,
you have to have on a fucking wife beater.
And I just fucking,
I know how I stand back from the window
so I can get some velocity and I just
side on that thing right out and
I hit that fucking thing right.
And it's God damn beak,
you know, not a headshot.
It can still walk away from
it every fucking morning.
Okay.
Of this morning. It didn't, it didn't.
But I had a add some company and
they were getting up at fucking, uh,
four 30 in the fucking morning cause
they had an early flight. And uh,
you know, it's funny. So they
got up and they said goodbye,
so we said goodbye. All right, thanks.
Thanks for visiting. We'll see you later.
Right. So they leave and right as they
start to go back asleep again, right,
right around when this fucking crows
going to start doing this. God Damn
like it's,
it's tied to something and it's slowly
being beaten with a fucking rubber hose.
Right.
The fucking bird makes no noise.
So Billy boy is just sleeping
away and what happens?
My fucking phone makes
a god goddamn noise.
And it was the people who stayed with us
texting me to let me know that they had
missed their flight, you know?
And I'm like, wow, that sucks.
Lax is horrible.
Send trying to go back to sleep.
And then right as I fall asleep again,
they send another text to be like, oh,
we made it.
Yeah.
You know that couldn't have waited til
9:00 AM you couldn't tell me about your
exciting little trip to
the fucking airport though.
Texting me every five seconds. Oh my God,
you should see the line down here. Stand.
Then I'm asleep and he goes boom. Right
my fucking ear. What does it do bill?
It goes blue.
I can't do the fucking noise.
What am I Michael Winslow go rent one of
the police academy movies and just say,
just fantasize how he would
have fucking done it. So,
oh, I know it saved the sugars. Fucking
hit me. The salt. I'm starting to crash.
Having you guys just felt my energy,
my energy started going down.
It's kind of like back in the day when
before iTunes when you actually bought
albums and you heard a song on the radio
and you fucking loved it and you were
about three tracks in right now and you
realize the song you heard on the radio
was the only good one.
That's what this podcast is going to be.
This podcast is going to
be like a Cinderella album.
You know? Speaking of that,
I have to download, shake me.
I heard that the other day when
I went to the fucking kings, uh,
Bruins, the kinks, Voca, the sugar is
killing me. The kings fucking Bruins
and that song came out shake.
Oh yeah.
I think that's all he says
for five minutes. Shake me.
Which I don't even understand what that
meant. I think it's somehow it has to be,
it's some sort of a sexual innuendo,
but I don't know what that means is he
liked her to walk up and rather than
shake his hand, just grab
his Dick. Hello. How are you?
I'll be the woman fucking you this
evening. Um, I dunno, but you know what?
I'm going to download it. I've been
downloading a lot of weird shit lately.
I downloaded that Bob Dylan song tangled
up in blue where he sings about every
woman he ever banged.
She was working in a fucking diner,
an hour dealing with my
hat. She said, son, it is,
and as big and I fucking said,
and I went down in the bud and
tangled up in blue. Right. Every
time you'd think it's fucking over.
Then I in a fucking girl named
Susan bound side of the road. Ooh.
She bent down to tie my shoes
and a blue fucking alone.
She wiped it off and looked at me.
Then why did you fucking do
dad 20 fucking minutes song,
you know, tangled and you sit there
and try to sing along with you guys.
Hey, you know, you just, you just
chime in the end. Every time.
Tangled up in blue begging
it. Bap Bap Purdue. Alright,
I'm sorry that that last little dead.
He was brought to you by cheesecake.
Cheesecake.
The breakfast of champions.
I swear I'm going for in 2012 man tents.
That's what I want.
That's what the ladies are looking for,
you know,
and when I wear my wife beater and yell
at that car when there'll be copping
them ever. So shapely, you know, hey,
if you get man tests,
do you have a higher chance of
getting breast cancer as a male?
Just started curiosity because I don't
think you can get breast cancer as a male
if you don't have man tits. It's like
getting cancer of the air, you know,
they don't exist. They're
not there. Right. Okay.
Who has no medical background.
All right. Moving on.
So I went to the fucking Bruins
game, right man. This, this guy, uh,
you know, uh, got me tickets, right? One
of the guys they play pick up hockey with.
Oh, by the way, pill, when
you play pick up hockey,
do you wear anything to protect your feet?
As a matter of fact,
I know I've been wearing skate fenders
warm for the first time last week and an
actual fucking game. I skated around
in a public rink with them, you know,
and uh, as opposed to my
private rank that I have outback
fucking idiot. I'm an idiot.
I'm a fucking area. So, um,
I used them in a game and I took one
off the foot and I didn't even feel it.
And I was able to continue scaling out
there at the mediocre level that I play
that wonderful game.
Skate fenders.com everybody go
there and get yourself a pair.
Stop being a fucking pussy.
Stop being the person who doesn't want
to go down to the rank and be the first
guy wearing them a right.
I went to the blues kings game and
the Bruins a kings game this week.
And why can't you just say,
I went to the king's game when the back
to back where they play the blues and
the Bruins. I could have
edited that together a little
better. Don't you think? Um,
and I saw a lot of guys out
there wearing them. You know,
and if it's good enough for them,
why can't you wear,
you don't want to get made fun
of. How old are you? All right,
you're an accountant. You're not
making it into the NHL. Okay?
So go to escape fender.com. Type in
Bill Burr, all one word, all lowercase.
You get $5 off. Protect
your fate. You know,
how are you going to stand up when
you're 80 on your porch and be good,
right? If you've been
taken pucks, see afoot.
No fucking kids are going to take you
seriously if he can't get up off your
chair on the porch, all right? To go to
escape fetter.com get yourself a pair.
If you don't even play hockey, just put
them on your loafers, shuffle around,
shuffle around your kitchen,
and then say everything you
always wanted to say to your wife.
And when she goes to stomp on your foot,
you're not going to feel it.
And she's going to get bone
spurs. Okay? So anyway,
so I went to the king's Bruins game.
That was a commercial, by the way.
I went to the Bruins kings game and uh,
so one of the guys I play hockey with,
he woke me up with these tickets
and they have like a club.
This is how fucking La la is.
It was a club.
And in between periods,
like you sit down and immediately
everybody who sits down you, you have to,
you walk in,
they take your credit card and your
license just fucking walk with that Shit,
right? Then they got all these, these
uh, almost hot waitresses walking around,
you know what I mean?
You don't want almost hot is that means
your body is slamming and so is your
face except into a wall.
It wasn't even that she wasn't
good looking. She just was a cunt.
You know the way all beautiful women,
our account. Why cause it beautiful.
Not all of them, but most of them.
They got that fucking, I'm beautiful.
Everybody wants to bang me. I don't even
have to fucking try attitude. Right.
This fucking won't this Horman she
comes by once in the first period.
Okay. So I walk by, I'm trying
to understand, I'm showing
a little empathy. I said,
hey sweetheart, I had to go find her
sweetheart with your midriff showing,
you know, listen, I know you're busy,
but if you get a chance, can you,
can you swing by again? And she gives me
this fucking look like I just asked her,
I dunno to help me move or something.
Hey, can you help me hang this picture?
Like I said, that I didn't, I
just said, hey, if you don't mind,
could you do your fucking job more
than once in the first peer in the next
period. But was funny. It
was in between periods. Um,
though it turns into like a dance club.
Like they just start playing like all
this fucking techno music. Alright.
And or whatever the fuck that they
play in all that, all that crap. It's,
so they basically take every
song and then they put that
beat underneath it and I'm
sitting behind me was um,
what do you call a group of gay
guys? Like I know like a, uh,
like a bunch of cows is a herd and he
gay listeners out there any twinkle toes
can tell me,
what do you call,
just a pack of gay guys that look like
a fucking j crew ad just sitting behind
us.
And one of them was lance bass lads bass.
Was that the game looking younger
than he did when he was in,
in sync?
So this is my question.
When is somebody in
the television, uh, um,
or whatever in the beauty products saying,
you know,
they have like now they have like the
UFC workout, they got the fucking, uh,
the grapefruit 45 die there. He always
got some fucking thing. What is,
somebody's got to figure out what gay
guys do. So they don't age. You know,
Dick Clark somehow figured it out.
You know
it's guy and you like, cause
I was looking at, I've gone,
that's not lance bass personal is
what's going. That's Lance Bass. I go,
no it isn't.
He still looks like he's fucking 22.
That kid's got to be like 50 by now. And
he wasn't, he was just you sitting there.
I still don't think it was him.
I thought it was like Wayne Gretzky Sun.
That's what it looked like.
You know you are Jesus Christ.
Wayne Gretzky looks like a straight lance
bass. I never realized that. See that.
That's why I do this podcast people.
I do it. So I learned something. Um,
Oh God, what do I got left here?
I just, I, you know something,
I haven't been on stage in
like three fucking weeks and
it's really affecting me.
Look at me. I'm running out of, I
don't have any comedy cardio anymore.
I'm 13 minutes, 25 seconds in and
I'm ready for this thing to be done.
It's like I came out and I got fucking
shelled and the first two winnings,
you know, and the managers
walking out of the dugout and I'm,
I'm walking towards him.
You know that that's when you know you
suck is you don't even wait until the
manager gets there.
You start walking off the mound,
you meet him at the first baseline, handed
the ball. Yay. Got It today. All right,
I'm going to get my shoulder rub down in,
uh,
I don't know what I'm gonna have to rub
one out cause there's no way I'm getting
pussy after that performance. Um,
you guys have the MLB channel.
That's one of the great things.
They actually haven't the NC 17 MLB late
night and that way they make up all the
players. You get to hear everything. I
actually heard a guy in the twin say what?
I just said, I just want to get
busted for a plagiarism. You know,
that's one of my ideas.
That's why I can never get a t a TV show
is my ideas never seem to fit into the
room. Oh, Bill, you just such a fucking
rebel, aren't you? I think I am.
I think I'm pat myself on the back
here now. You know where it is.
I have great ideas,
but they all are not conducive
to a mass audience and children.
I think that that's what the problem is.
So if anybody can help me with this one,
I have an idea.
Okay.
Uh, for a new level of
watching sports, it's NFL,
NC 17 MLB,
NC 17 NBA,
NC 17, and you guessed
it, a worldwide tennis,
no, NHL NC 17. And basically
you just Mike Up. Everybody.
Okay.
It's for adults only.
And rather than hearing the
people commentate the game,
you actually just people,
you just hear him cursing each other
out as we go down the fucking court.
Skate down the ice. You
fucking cock suck out. Right.
That's what I want to hear.
I wanna hear that shit.
Like when a manager goes up
and just be like, you know,
do you realize that you're supposed
to be throwing strikes here?
Well this is like the third fucking
start in a row. You tubby shit out,
but you do some sit ups. I know
CC's fat, but it works for him.
It's not working for you.
Get the fuck Outta here. Ah,
Jesus Christ.
Did we get any more Dominican's left?
These fucking white
guys can't pitch anymore
and that'd be great.
Or like with two players in the same
team really fucking get into it.
That will be great. But you know, it would
suck, would be the, uh, the reporters.
Cause then the reporters would hear all
of it and they'd have even more bullshit
soap opera crap to write about.
You know,
cause I don't want to,
I know,
I just want to listen to him shooting
the shit and trashing each other.
And uh, then afterwards I don't need them
to be like, why did you call Tom Brady?
You're fucking adware and dose.
Like, I don't need to know why.
I don't care. I just want to hear it,
you know? I mean, we'll fucking times,
cause I listened to these commentators
don't tell you up paying manning I got to
be taken. Is that ere going to be
too thin for my big fucking head?
Well, my head move faster
in the thin atmosphere. Um,
speaking of which, is herm Edwards doing
a parody of an ESPN analysts or is it,
is he really, you know, are they
putting something in his drink?
I don't understand that guy. That's a guy
who played the game for over 20 years.
He coached it for like fucking 10,
15. It doesn't have anything to say
is,
is he somehow related to flavor?
Flave I don't understand what that
guy is doing on their channel.
He starts like really slow and then out
of nowhere he just yells and then looks
at the other guy,
a the patriots to play in the cults today.
What do you think Khurram Edwards?
Well,
I tell you,
you got two guys on either side of the
ball that really know how to throw a
raptor. I'm going to be about Blah
Blah and he fuck it. Looks off.
What the fuck just happened? It's
almost like he's gonna, he's,
he's about ready to have some sort of
epileptic fit and he's trying to get his
fucking sentence out before his eyes
rolled back and he falls off that share
that, you know, they got at
staples, even if it is ESPN,
those corporate concert
we're always trying to cut.
They're always trying to cut corners,
you know.
All right bill. That went nowhere and it
just came to a fucking screeching halt.
I brought my car over to get it fixed
today cause I was parked at a meter and
somebody somehow, I don't know, they
didn't side swipe, they didn't t bone it.
It's almost like they just came in at
a 45 degree angle and said I hate that
front quarter panel.
And they just slammed into it and a right
at the last second when they thought
they were going to drive it into my poor
excuse for an engine block on that car.
They just cut the wheel. Um, I don't know
if it was a three point turn gone wrong.
I don't know.
Somebody should have done a three point
turn and tried to do a one point Youi I
have no idea how the fuck could
have happened, but I brought,
I just brought it over there to some guy
named rusty who's fucking breath smell
like cigarettes.
He smoked in 1972
and then I walked over to fucking, uh,
the rental car, place one over to ava.
I wore red fucking blazer for hoping
that will get me a discount and
okay.
I come walking out to the parking
lot. They go like, okay, miss you bro.
You chose a mid sized car.
We have a fucking whatever the fuck.
It wasn't a long day. I don't know what
cards they were even called anymore.
Right with,
would that be to your liking?
And I'm looking at this blue
space ship and I'm like, uh,
what else do you got actually sure.
That's all we have in the midst.
Then why did you just say is that to my
liking? You will hope it. I'd be local.
Yeah. Yeah it is. And then
you could just continue.
I just called your bluff their
world series at [inaudible].
What else you got while we can I point
here, you'd have to upgrade you an SUV.
So I'm looking at this
fucking car headlights and
brake lights wrap all the way
around like those Lance Armstrong glasses,
you know,
it's Blue Cube and uh,
and I'm looking on the back and I'm like,
is it a Honda? Is that what that age is?
It's sort of a fucked up looking at age.
Janetta was a Hyundai.
I'm driving a Hyundai people and which
from a Prius to a Hyundai, you know,
and uh, my balls of completely
pulled up inside my body,
you know, Hyundai really
ripped off Honda's h you know,
they kind of turn it to the side a
little bit to full old guys like me,
you know, I don't fucking know
fucking girls. I get winded,
I can dry heave. Um, let's,
let's, let's, let's go into the, uh,
the letters for this week. People. I,
I really felt like this podcast was going
to be great and I had all this shit to
talk about and now I'm just feeling like
I've run out of things to stay and it's
scaring me. Anti car. Hey Bill,
what are the drawbacks
of having an antique car?
I've always wanted a a 55 Chevy Bel Air.
And hearing you talk about your truck
has made me realize I should do it while
I'm still young. Abso-Fucking-Lutely
I got to tell you right now,
there is no drawback to having
an antique car. All right?
If you just mentally except a few things,
a, it's fucking old. B,
you're going to have to do
some things to it and see.
You're going to feel like 1 million bucks
when you drive down the street. Okay?
There's a tradeoff for
everything. All right?
And um,
you definitely want to do it while you
still young because you know you're going
to get married,
you can have kids and you know,
your wife's going to be thinking
about the kids going, is that safe?
I don't think it's safe.
You know that you're going to hear it,
you know, through your mail
ears. All you're going to
hear is, are you having fun?
I don't want you to have fun.
I want your life to be miserable.
And then you've got a call or something
horrific name in front of your fucking
kids and then that's going to be it,
you know, and then you'll have your car,
you'll be fucking living in
it. Um, look, I, I, there's,
you know what the drawback is?
It depends on what you buy.
If you buy something really like a,
okay.
I dunno,
like rare that a lot of people don't
have the drawback is trying to get parts.
If you buy it like a Mustang or Camaro,
there's evidently there's parts
for days on those kinds of cars.
And I also would think a Chevy bel air
that's like, you're buying a classic,
like a classic of the
classics. So, you know,
I mean I even think like a Bel aire is
one of those cars that you can actually,
if you have like 300 grand, if they'll
just make you a brand new one. You know?
Cause I know you can do that with like
a stick of fucking 68 Camaro somewhere
online. I saw that they'll just
build you one, a brand new one.
It costs like $170,000 for
some stupid fucking reason.
Um,
it costs all that money.
Okay.
You know,
which I kind of look at that.
That's like cds and when they came out
and they was 17 bucks and eventually
you're going to come down, they don't, um,
yeah,
to my laptop is fucked. I have to buy a
new one. It's like all it's filled up.
Okay.
Why I'm getting that little pinwheel.
Why is it still doing that enough already?
Okay.
Um,
so no,
there is no drawback to have an antique
car unless you just buy a complete hunk
of shit that had a,
uh,
a major accident and the
guy's not honest about it.
And then you got yourself a fucking lemon.
That would be the drawbacks.
So what I would do is find a friend
of yours who's a fucking gearhead and
they'll help you out. You know,
like I, that's what I did with mine.
And,
um,
once I got the okay from the dude and
he said it was a solid vehicle than a,
I went ahead and I got it. Yeah, no,
I was just thinking the other day I was
actually took it out on the highway man
and whoever the fuck had it before me,
really baby Dick. I'm the fourth owner.
But the first two owners
had it from 68 to 2009.
So I think that was a father son than
somebody else bought it and the recession
hit and they had to get rid of it.
But it drives,
like they change the oil every 3000 miles,
which is a,
a is a huge thing. So, um, I dunno what
the fuck, what is this? The speed channel?
Hey, bill baseball. Are we in for good
baseball season? Uh, I have no idea.
It seems as if somebody says,
it seems as if the past few years
have been terrible seasons with the
expectation, with the exception
of a few good playoff series,
though I'm sure they wouldn't have been
as exciting without the exaggerated
rivalries since when is a cubs
Padres series been monumental?
Maybe it's just me.
I think the last time a cubs pod race
season was Ma us series was monumental.
Might have been the early
eighties Tony Gwynn, Leon Durham,
Bill Buck now, um, you know,
somebody said they brought up bill
Buckner to me the other day and they would
just say, yeah, yeah, I saw this
whole thing, how we had to move.
He had to leave Boston after that and
just like, I just don't understand that.
The shock of that. Yeah.
Yeah. You have to leave. Yeah.
You fucked up a world series
that people at that point,
he'd been waiting 70 something years and
you'll let it roll through your legs.
Gee,
did you have a difficult time?
Okay.
Abdalla yelling at his kids too.
Yeah. Yeah. I would assume that.
I would assume that that was, that's
what would happen. You've been to a game,
you hear the shit that people yell.
You hear the stuff that people say,
what do you think you're special.
I don't fucking, I don't, you know,
I'm not saying it's right by just,
I don't understand the shock.
That's like after nine 11 when Arabs
were complaining that they were getting
harassed at the airport.
Yeah. Yeah. That's going to,
I would think that that would happen the
same way as if fucking 20 redheads went
out and did some fucked up shit.
I would expect to be getting some looks
the next day. I'm not saying it's right,
I don't condone it,
but I wouldn't sit there dumbfounded
going to move to Ireland and get with all
the other fucking redheaded cons.
You know,
cause everyone was staring
at me and Connecticut.
I just fucking blows my mind every
time they bring up shit like that.
Like that,
that fucking kid there in Chicago.
I mean a whole sad sack story about that
fucking kid who reached out and touched
the ball that was fucking in play
or they had a shot at, you know,
you only thing that confuses me about
that story is why they didn't hunt down
the other five fucking cunts around them
who were also reaching up for the ball.
That's the only way I will defend
that guy. But other than that,
you know when you,
when you touch a ball that's playable
and one of the athletes points that you
like, what the fuck you got to?
Why would you still sit there?
You immediately,
you've got to get the fuck out of there.
Now I'm not saying that you should go
on the radio and out the guy and say who
the fuck he is.
What I'm saying is my ex,
my expectation for human behavior
in a and a crowd is very,
very low. You know, I mean, come on.
How many people fucking have kids and
you want to take him to a game and then
you think about the last time you went to
a game, you're like, hey, you know what?
I'll wait till the kids a little bit
older alum of let's try to extend his
fucking childhood a little bit.
Okay. People are assholes, you know,
that's why like,
I dunno,
I've been all over the map politically,
but it's why like, you know,
certain ways of looking at shit,
like when people talk about guns land,
let's just make them,
well,
let's just make them illegal and
then nobody will have them. You know,
like that's sort of like
thought process is you're,
you're acting as though the world is a
utopia and that there's not morons and
that there's not, uh, people who say,
I don't give a fuck what the rules are.
You're totally not even taking
into consideration paths,
which is why that new fucking
thing that Obama signed,
that whole defense package where now they
can just arrest people without a trial
j and put you in jail forever with,
without a trial because they just
think you're a fucking terrorist.
You can't give people that level of power.
I'm a fucking moron. And I know
you can't do that. Historically,
no one has ever handled
that level of power. Well,
anybody here want to go live in China now
we out there practicing your nunchucks
wearing your wooden slippers and all
of a sudden a van pulls up and you
disappear and that's it forever. You
want to live there? Of course you don't.
You want to live here where they can't
fucking do it. Well, they can do it now.
You know? They just put in a fucking
order for a bunch of black fans.
That's what I heard. According to Holy
shit.com that's what's going down.
I don't understand why stuff at that
level that affects citizens to that level.
Why we don't get to vote on it.
Do you think it's because we'd
say, Hey, you know what? Fuck that.
Do you want to stand like
that is just a jump off point.
Do you think like that's just how it's
going to swell zone terrorist dinner.
You ain't got to fuck bro. You think
it's just going to stop with that.
That's not how you take away freedom.
You don't just fucking do it all at
one fail swoop. It's incremental.
It's just like when you're dating some
fucking woman and you're not paying
attention and she just gradually, every
day takes another foot of real estate.
Next thing you know you're
in goal line d going,
how the fuck did I end up in
this situation? We started
at the 50 little push,
a little poll, right? Everything was
fine. The casino Europe against the Golan,
the you think that they're just going
to keep it with the terrorist thing,
you know?
You know they'll wait for a whole nother
generation of babies to be born and
they always grew up with government having
that level of power and then they had
something else to it. Then they
had something else. Then that's it.
You can't have,
okay,
if tiger woods can't handle the
level of free pussy on a golf tour,
how the fuck is our government going
to handle a new defense package,
which basically gave them a mute button
when you love that,
how would handle that if
you had that power, do you,
how long before you just
started abusing that?
If you could just hit mute on anybody
who ever disagreed with you and it just,
and you could have them whisked away.
I mean that is just sociopath's wet dream.
That's what that is. That is a
fucking mute button, Mr Style.
And don't you think that's it? He hit
mute. You're done. You're gone. See Ya.
I think,
I think it's fucking insane and I'm,
the only thing that I get out of it is
that I feel like I was proven correct
that I don't think it
matters at that level.
Whether you vote Democrat or Republican
Obama, the first black president ever,
you would think this
would be the most liberal
a politician in the
history of this country
because of his background. You would
think that he signed off on that shit.
Yeah.
All right. I'm telling you, I don't know
what happens when you become president,
but I think they let you peek just
enough behind the curtain and there was a
fucking agenda that we are moving towards.
Cause it does.
I don't think it fucking matters.
I really don't,
which is why I always
vote for the Ralph Nader.
The fucking Ron Paul, all those guys that
all those fucking idiots go, oh gosh,
you did that. You've ruined
the election. Really? Did I?
Okay.
I feel like those guys wouldn't
have signed shit like that.
I feel like their track record shows that
they would not sign shit like that. I,
I dunno,
I have no,
I imagine I'm going to get
a ton of fucking emails I'm
on with somebody who was
yelling at me one time saying that
because I voted for Ralph Nader in 2000.
That's why George W.
Bush won.
And they were just going on and on
and on about it. And I was like, dude,
I live in New York. Al
Gore won my state. Okay,
get a stand that, so your whole fucking
theory right now is out the window.
I voted for Ralph Nader in New York
and Al Gore still won the state.
So go fuck yourself. What
I'm trying to do, uh,
Mister fucking red and blue tie here,
I'm trying to fucking encourage
more people like that to vote.
So mission accomplished. That's what I'm
trying to fuck. You have to vote to run.
You know
uncorruptible how far can you get if
you're uncorruptible I would say that you
can get to the uh,
okay.
Whatever level politics is when you
decide whether or not they should put a
gazebo in the center of town. I think
beat. Once you get beyond that, you got,
you gotta be a little dirty.
Right.
I love talking about this shit cause
it just stirs people up, you know?
Oh you know,
maybe you should all read a little
before the next time you fucking own.
Really. What are you reading? What
do you written? What they give you?
Is that what you read and fuck head.
Why you acting like you have clearance
to the bottom floors are the fucking
Pentagon. You're guessing?
Just like I am. All right,
Mr informed I read the pamphlet.
I know.
Buy a fucking word of it.
You know you can use coca cola
to take rust off of metal.
You can use it for that.
You know,
you understand that yet they're
still able to sell it to us.
Like it's refreshing.
I don't know what that point meant either.
I thought I had a point there.
Fuck you. I'm full of sugar and
salt. Them crashing right now.
Crashing and burning. All right, let's
get him on to some more shit here. Uh Oh,
I have bill. We had for a good baseball
season. I don't, I have no idea.
All I know is I am not what the, come
on man. Don't fucking do this to me.
You fucking cunt. I can't scroll down
because I'm getting the pinwheel.
Oh Krista, it's time for a
commercial. Everybody. amazon.com.
Do you like this podcast? No. Well
then fucking listen to another one
who's left. All right. You guys
liked this podcast. Well, thank you.
I appreciate it. Um, if you would like to
donate to this podcast, it's very easy.
All you gotta do is next time you think
about buying something on amazon.com
rather than going directly to amazon.com,
go to [inaudible] dot com click on the
podcast page and on the right hand side
you're going to see the Amazon banner,
Pam, Pam, Pam, Pam, Pam, right, Amazon.
There was the whalers goal
song, the Amazon, a banner.
You Click on that and then just
go buy something. All right?
It doesn't change the price. You don't
have to put in any passwords, nothing.
Just go to amazon.com through
my website on the podcast page.
You Click on the banner,
you buy something,
they'll kick me back a percentage and
10% of that will go to the wounded
warriors project. So with you going
out and buying yourself a new Flowbee,
maybe a pen and pencil set,
maybe you get yourself a mountain bike
because you decided you're finally going
to get yourself in shape, right? And
rather than just going for a walk,
you feel you need to punish
your body cause you grew up
in the era of Ken Patera,
right? Whatever you're going to do
just now, when you buy that thing,
a little bit of money goes to the Monday
morning podcast and 10% of that money
goes to help the troops. All right?
Killed two birds with one stone.
And you could walk down the street and
say, you know what? I am a good person.
So there you go. All right, let's
try and find where these fucking
come on. Where the hell of the
questions here. And so my question, um,
all right. Oh, this is a
question about Dave Grohl. Bill,
I love the podcast. I wanted to see if
you would go on a rant on my behalf. Um,
first I would like to start up by saying
that I'm a recording engineer and you
being a drummer should be
upset by this to, okay.
He's already dragging me.
And uh,
during Dave Grohl Grammy
Acceptance Speech,
he said that their new album was special
because they recorded it in his garage
with a couple of microphones.
Uh,
most people would hear that
and think that's pretty cool.
But this really pisses me off.
At what point does a four point $5
million recording studio stop being,
uh, being a garage? I mean,
it may say it's a garage
on the blueprints,
but it's not like their drummer is getting
his sticks caught in a fishnet. Also,
I attached a photo of the drum set
that they use during the recording.
I counted 13 microphones.
That's a lot more than a couple.
If it pisses you off at all.
I would love to hear your thoughts
about it on the podcast. Well look,
I think what he was really doing
was he was going off on auto tune.
So in a roundabout way he,
he's helping you out, isn't he?
Cause he did do it on a student
in a, in a, in a studio.
I think it was more ethnic.
It was making fun of a auto too,
wasn't he? And I'm really
trying to give you an example.
One of those umbrella
Ella Ella a that shit.
Right? Wasn't he just kind of making
fun of that? He did do it in his garage,
surf. At the end of the day,
if they took those drums out,
he could put one of his 47 cars in there.
So technically it is still a garage.
He should not have said a couple of
microphones if you want to get conti.
All right. But you know what? I bet
he had an engineer in there, you know,
I bet somebody's got some work out
of that. I think he's on your team.
You know,
I'm sorry
you went to the wrong guy in this one.
Being a drummer,
Dave Grohl would basically have to be
sacrificing babies before I ever gave them
any shit because uh,
I have a fan boy crush on him so I can't
really trash them because in my twisted
fucking narcissistic world,
I think I actually have a chance of
meeting him and maybe playing drums on one
track on his next album. That's,
that's the lofty area my ego lives in.
You know what I should
do one of these weeks,
I should actually play drums for you
guys or maybe guitar and you can hear a
fucking awful I am and then he can trash
me and feel better about yourselves.
Isn't that fun?
Does that make you feel good to watch
somebody attempt something and then
completely fail and then
you get that, that, that,
that warm feeling in
your chest we you like,
see that's what happens when you try.
That's what happens when
you go after your dreams.
I knew I was right by choosing this job
that was safe rather than fulfilling.
Isn't that what you do
fucking cunts? First of all,
Mr Engineer,
you are in a situation now where you could
build your own fucking can't you with
like a laptop and a Frisbee.
Why don't you start recording all these
up and coming bands gets your foot in
the fucking door and
then as as they rise up,
doe maybe they'll take you with them.
I think there's an unbelievable fucking
opportunity here right now for artists
to take control of their fucking careers
and not have to have these cons taken
all your money, all that fucking behind
the music, shit, all these things.
You work hard,
you recorded a special,
you get in business with
somebody and then you know,
okay,
I'm fucking,
I'm waiting for money right now.
People buy DVDs and I had some
out. Doesn't get to me. Oh, we had,
we had a hundred grand in
whiteout expenses. Sorry Bill.
Sorry. No money for you. We're
keeping it all ourselves.
Then eventually we go out of
business and you're chasing a ghost.
We all take a bonus out of the money
that we owed you and a bunch of other
fucking comedians we take off and
then you're suing the corporation,
which is not a person and nobody works
here anymore. So well good luck to you.
I understand what you're
saying sir. I understand. Okay,
let me give day grove a
little bit of shit he made.
Really did make it sound like,
hey man,
we just go like a bag of weed and cleared
out the rakes in the fucking wheel
barrow.
We made like an album man. And like
that's all you really need to do man.
Because like it's all about the music
and like if you really believe in it,
people can like feel it man. You
know what I'm saying? I know he
did do that.
It did do that.
But at the end of the day he did
record it at his house. You know,
he should've said, I recorded
it in what used to be my garage,
but what is now the equivalent
to recording at capital,
and I'll tell you,
all you got to be is a monster rock star
who's been selling millions of albums
for 20 years.
And you could do it too.
So you don't need autotune boys and
girls despite the fact that it puts you
right. You know, I read
about some fucking,
this little spazzy look a nerd and rolling
stone who makes some sort of fucking
music with, with a Macintosh. Um,
which to me, I don't give
a fuck is not, it is music,
but it isn't.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
This just, I, it's more like you
are, it's like you're an editor.
I would say it's, it's more
like that. Like, I don't,
I don't think that what you're doing, it's
like you are making music, but you're,
you're taking sounds in all this
shit that you don't have the,
have the ability to make, I guess that
one guy that fat Gail made all those,
those loops for Justin Timberlake and uh,
and Jay Z, who's that guy who have
it be pay, pay, pay, pay, pay, pay,
pay, Yoda. It's hard
to death that that guy,
I guess that, yeah. Guy Is,
I saw him. He can actually
play instruments and shit.
Oh, well, you know what I'm,
I'm painting with a broad brush
here. People, I'm just saying I own,
I was saying halfway through
that I fucking got lost in,
in the sugar of cheesecake at
eight in the fucking morning. Um,
okay.
Was there a point? Oh yeah. I was
reading about this fucking nerd,
which by the way, people can, can,
can nerds go back to being beaten
for no fucking reason at all.
You know, I, I really can't
wait for the backlash on nerds.
I've had it with them.
I've had it with them and bracing
the fact that they're awkward to,
to the point of pretending to
be awkward even when you're not,
and just coming up to you and be and
am awkward and then believing all the
pressure of the conversation
on you. You know, fucking 30,
35 years old walking around acting like
some 14 year old on his first date.
Yeah.
You know what? Somebody has that this
week. Where the hell is it? The overrated,
underrated for the weeks,
uh,
overrated dorks they're taking over and
they haven't even done anything cool to
earn it. Fuck the office, Dude.
I gotta be honest with you.
I've been saying that for fucking years.
My girl loves that show the office.
All right. And I can't
fucking watch it. All right.
It's like,
can somebody on that show be like,
be aware of what they're saying when
they're saying it instead of like
afterwards, immediately
afterwards, you know.
Okay.
I,
I did like their cartoons.
Okay.
Fucking every goddamn one
of those fucking shows.
I can't,
I can't get into the shit.
I can't get into the ship because I'm
gonna start trashing shit and then you can
think straight across the board that I
fucking like anybody in the alt scene.
That's not fucking true.
But
okay.
I think,
I think the alternative comedy scene is
like the hair metal scene in late 1989
all right.
We're about a year away before never
mind is going to come out and they're all
going to be scurried.
And I'm going to,
I can't fucking wait because
I'm just an old country redhead.
No, I reside, I actually
on, I do resent the,
the alternative scene
full for one reason only.
And that's because that scene created
a situation that it basically distilled
all of the horror out of
attempting to be a comedian.
That's what I don't like about it.
Okay.
No haggling, no drugs,
no obnoxious behavior,
no aggressiveness from every fucking
reason that it takes balls to be a
comedian. Every fucking reason why
people who wanted to be a comic,
but it never fucking did it. You've
removed from that situation and you've
just created like this
fucking comedy womb, you know,
and, and on top of that, it's like
you're performing to just this,
this, it's like a radio station.
It's not even a crowd. It's like,
what did I go to fucking radio station?
I only perform to hipsters ages 18 to 24
who were skinny fucking loose jeans and
have black frame glasses.
It's like,
and then if they have to go
down to a fucking comedy club,
when they're jokes don't go
over, they, they act like the,
the crowd is dumb rather than, no, you,
you're like a specialist.
You like that guy who plays
on the football team and
only goes out is you like
the long snapper.
You know what I mean?
You can only could play one fucking
position and you turn around and you're
blaming the fucking crowd.
I Dunno dude.
I just, it's, it's, and
then on top of that,
the amount of shots that
over the fucking years
they've taken a club comics, like we're
all a bunch of hacks over there, you know,
talking about
plain food. Like they're above
us. And then every fucking to,
I got to talk to Bob and talked to Bobby
Kelly about this shit on his podcast.
Hopefully this week, cause we were
talking about some of this shit.
And anytime then what happens is right
then you go to do some benefit or you
going to do some sort of fucking comedy
festival and then they put club comics
and all comics together. And
what happens? All those fucking,
all comics go on early.
You know,
one in particular is
always fucking trading up.
He can't go on early enough despite the
fact his face is all over the fucking
posters. And then who's got a mop up in
the end, two hours into the fucking show,
a club comic, you know, uh,
those fucking all comics and they're
all fucking nice to you on those shows.
He raises his real Dick van. You clicking
really? Are you? Are you, they're nervous.
Go on second, go on third and then fucking
run out with your book bag. You can't,
ah, the flood gates have opened. I've
had it. I've had it with fucking nervous.
I've, I've, I've, I've fuck it.
I get it. I get it. All right,
you're into comic con. I get it.
And if you're not into comic con,
then you're fucking stupid.
Is that basically what it is?
Cheesecake baby.
It's the cheesecake.
Just for the record. The old scene was
started by club comics. All those guys,
David Cross, Bob Odenkirk, Dana
Gould, Mark Marin, beast, all of them,
all of them, they could
perform in fucking, uh,
an offtrack betting and
they could have a great set.
Okay.
But inadvertently I think,
you know what they did,
they're almost like rich people who
have kids, you know, and they, they,
they struggled up through all this shit,
right?
And then they just have these kids in
their first car is like a Maserati and
they wrap it around a pole and there's
like no ramification. That's that.
That is my overall generalization of my
problem that I have with the AllSeen is,
um, it's, it's like, uh,
it's like standup comedy while wearing
like the training wheels and he never
take them off. Okay, bill, we got it.
You've, you've made, you've, you've,
you've made your, your fucking one sided
argument. Um, all right, there we go.
That out against some fucking
emails that aren't into it.
I'm trying to be controversial
this week and other overrated,
chasing your dreams.
Stay home. Jesus Christ.
How many hugs did you not get, sir? Um,
although that's funny. Uh, underrated, uh,
watching a whole series on Netflix
in three weeks. Is there anything,
is there anything better than being
able to skip commercials and weeks of
waiting for Shit to happen? Who cares
about spoilers? From what I understand,
die hard. Fans of loss. Can't
even explain the last episode.
No spoilers there Jr is dead and
I'll never go back and watch Dallas.
Um,
I think it's good.
It's good and bad because
when, when you, uh,
the anticipation of it coming out,
you know,
like when people had to wait
for the next Beatles album,
what are they going to do?
How they're going to top the next one.
And then you'd go out,
you fucking stand in line to get
it and you sit down and wait.
It becomes like an event.
Um,
it's like having a slice of cake rather
than eating the whole fucking cake.
You know what I mean? So, but I do,
I do know what you're saying. Um,
and the whole fast forwarding through
commercials and that type of thing,
I actually, I do enjoy doing
that. I do enjoy doing that.
Even though I have commercials on my,
I'm such a fucking hypocrite.
It's ridiculous. And speaking to that,
how about another commercial right now,
what are we going to go with people? What
are we going to go with? What happens?
You're heard me say stamps.com
everybody. Hey this, this,
this is something that we've all
been going to our entire lives.
Something called the post office.
Okay.
And we go down there
with those crabby people.
You know who they can't get fired unless
the union boss says it's okay. Right.
And that down, they're leaning on shovels.
You asking for stamps am on break.
And they sit there with their fucking
chewing tobacco spitting into a spittoon.
Right.
Would it be great if you could just
have your own little post office in your
apartment in the garage like Dave Grohl
right next to your drum set with the 52
microphones on? It. Would it be
great if you could just totally,
you know, it'd be like if he
could somehow have the DMV
okay
in your apartment and just take your
own picture and make your own, damn, I
wouldn't that be great.
They're not going to let you do it because
it's all part of the new world order
man. But you can have the
post office in your house.
Wouldn't that be fantastic?
Would it be great to just
be able to print out stamps?
Said you could put on an envelope using
your computer and a little piece of
paper.
Wouldn't it be phenomenal to have your
own damn scale where you could weigh
things? It'd be that's how much
it weighs and here's the zip code.
How much does that cost?
Would it be wonderful to be able to
do that completely naked at two in the
morning while eating a pop tart?
Well, with stamps.com you can do it.
You can buy and print us postage official
US postage as opposed to that bootleg
stuff that's been out
there. All right. Um,
what's going on with my computer? I
got to get a new one. This one's full.
Um,
you can buy and print official US postage
using your own computer and printer
stand, stop. Chrom we'll
give you a digital scale.
Just plug it into you computer way.
Your letter or a package.
The exact amount of the postage will
automatically appear on the screen.
And I got to tell you, they're not
lying there because I've done it.
I had shipped DVDs to the four
core as it is country and I am,
he had to say, ask not what
your scale could do for you. Uh,
endorsement stamps.com is like having a
postal expert right at my desk expert.
I don't know about that. It's like
having a postal guy right at your desk,
except he doesn't have an attitude. How
about that? There's never any guesswork.
Um, and you never have
to go to the post office.
I haven't been there since
other than to drop off. Uh,
the stamps that I put it off cause I
live in a city and they won't pick up the
mail.
But if you live in the middle of nowhere,
you know when you've got a deer in the
front lawn, you know, taking a dump,
it's going to poison your food
somehow. You can, you know you can.
If you live out there and Mayberry,
you print out your stamps,
you stick in the box, she bring you
a little red flag up as if to say,
I have mail in here that
needs to be delivered. Um,
right now stamps.com has a
special offer for my listeners,
my listeners that I can arrest you and
detain you indefinitely without a trial.
If I even suspect that you're listening
to another podcast, use my last name,
Bird Capital B, u r,
R for a no risk trial.
Plus because you're my
listeners, I own you. All right?
You get $110 bonus offer that includes
a digital scale and $55 in free postage
of funny was it?
Listen to me.
Try to say scale a digital
scale and $55 in free postage.
Call to action verbatim. They want me
to read this word for word. Here we go.
Don't wait.
Index finger in the air.
Go to stamps.com before you
do anything else. All right?
I don't care if your grandmother's
wheezing. You go right to stamps.com.
Click on the radio microphone
at the top of the homepage.
You type in Burke Capital P,
U R R that stamps.com and to Burr,
get yourself the scale.
Get yourself some stamps and you don't
have to go down to the post office ever
again. You can just cut that audio life
like a cancer that you discovered early.
How do you link that?
Huh?
I think I'm gonna eat cheesecake
before I read the next one. Um, anyway,
and it just totally took me off track.
What the hell was I talking about?
What are we 53 minutes in,
53 minutes into this podcast and I'm going
to try to upload and I'm not going to
be able to cause my,
my stupid thing is full,
despite the fact that I've removed all
pictures and put them onto an external
hard drive. All right, where
are we? Male dance. Let's read this bill.
Bit of a bit of a dilemma here for you.
Oh,
before I do this,
why don't I give you guys emails cause
a lot of you guys are like, Bill,
I have things that I would
like to be read in a bad way,
in a second grade manner on the podcast.
Where do I email you
decide you can email me,
you can email me@billatthemmpodcast.com.
Don't forget that the all right bill at
the [inaudible] podcast.com and MMP is
all capitalized.
All right,
bill@themmpodcast.com and you
can tell me to go fuck myself.
You can ask me questions, you can ask
advice, she can do whatever you want.
Um, and that is, it built bit
of a dilemma here for Ya. Uh,
I'm an 18 year old male who's
about to graduate from high school.
Congratulations.
Um,
over the past few years I've been
told I'm a really good dancer. Uh,
not ballet or artsy stuff,
but just good dance floor dancing.
Oh my God, I'm going to take over the
dance floor. Hey Angie, who watched me?
You're John Travolta. This is
great. Do you go out to the, uh,
Staten Island Bridge and do headstands
with your, with your buddy Bobby?
You know, if he didn't have an Afro, he
never would have fell off that bridge.
If you had it high and tight. Like
all these Armenians out here, all,
every Armenian looks like they
know, uh, they, they know, um, um,
MMA moose,
last time you saw an our Armenian
dude in his twenties or thirties,
and he did not look like he could put
you in an arm bar within two seconds if
you want it to.
If I were,
if I was a Dana white and I was running
the UFC at one point at this point,
what they're up to like what?
Like UFC 2006,
you know, they're like, run it, they've
run out of adjectives this time.
It's really, really personal,
right? Not Saying I'm not a fan,
I'm a huge fucking fan.
I'm just saying, you know,
the way they have those things, like every
other week, there's only so many, like,
you know, redemption. I mean,
you've running out of words. Um,
I'm such a fucking idiot.
This is what I would do if I was dating
white at some point I would have,
you know, you know what I would,
this is what I would branch off.
And when they had those
tough man competitions and
they would have just people
coming in,
throwing haymakers,
which is some of the best boxing ever
is when you watch people who just aren't
trained whatsoever and they just start,
you know,
cause somebody's going to connect,
right?
I think that they should have one week
they should have the Armenians verse the
Russians tough man competition,
because I really think that that needs,
it needs to be decided who is
the tougher of the two, uh,
cause up more now when it
comes to white people. That's,
that's who I got my money
on. All right. That, those,
those are the crips and the bloods of
white people is the army and the Russians,
all of them, they just have that vibe.
Does something you just like. Yeah.
I'm not fucking with that guy. Just
really, I'm really not doing it anyways.
Uh,
not
a ballet or artsy stuff,
but just ballroom dance in a
full contention over here. Uh,
I kind of think of think dancing is
gay from an outside point of view.
Um, I, I, it isn't, it really isn't,
that's just how white people look at it.
It's considered gay cause it involves
like letting yourself go and actually
admitting that you have emotions as a
man, as a white male. Yeah. It's constant.
Yeah, it is. It's considered gay. Um,
as his crying,
as is showing any sort of emotion as is
not dying for no good God damn reason
before you 56, um, oh,
not dying. I should say.
If you live to be 60, I believe amongst
white men, that's also considered gay.
Cause that means at some point you cried
something out of your chest and you
didn't have a heart attack.
Um, anyways, he says,
I think a dancing is gay from
an outside point of view,
but I'll be the first one to admit that
I'm actually a pretty good dancer if I
didn't think so, I wouldn't be out
there doing it. Yeah. But Dude,
you gotta be getting some, I'll
fucking women love a guy who can dance,
dude. If you can dance and you were in
like a silk scarf, it's fucking over.
It's going to be rain in Pussy.
As far as my outside view,
my freckled view from over in the bar
trying to stand out from underneath those
hot lights so I don't
get burned. Uh, you know,
red heads were the closest
thing to vampires. You know,
we have,
we have none of the powers of vampires,
but the sun affects us the same way.
Okay.
A friend of mine who was a female dancer
keeps telling me I could make money
doing it on commercials or music videos.
Parentheses close on.
Or You could go to fucking Broadway.
It'd be like one of the five straight
men who dances on Broadway and just tag
every fucking lonely chick out
there who's all stretched out.
Just make sure you keep those shoes on.
Dancers' feet are always fucked up. Uh,
here's where it gets complicated.
I plan on becoming a policeman.
Okay?
Oh Dude, this is, this is a no
brainer. You need to dance it.
Bachelorette parties dressed
as a cop. All you need, dude,
is that a fake uniform on a boombox and
you're on your way to making money? Dude,
you should fucking do that in a second.
And then you write a book about it.
I was a gyrate and cop for Bachelorette
parties and you write a tell all book
about how many fucking broads, who bought
ready got married? You get married,
sucked your Dick. You really
need help on this one. I mean,
I'm going to read the rest of it,
but I think I've already
come with a solution anyways.
How is anyone supposed to take
me seriously on the force?
If there's a video going with me,
pop and locking next to little
Wayne at the same time, I'll, dude,
you should fucking pull people over.
Yeah,
you should pull people
over and fucking moon.
Walk up to their car
and just freak them out.
Even if they were reaching
for a gun, they'd be laughing
too hard and they, they,
they wouldn't shoot you. Then you
could rest them and then you move.
Next thing you know you're a
commissioner, right? Nothing. Anyways,
at the same time, I'm getting laid a
lot because of it. Of course you are.
I'm a seven on a scale of 10. I like
this guy. He's honest and um, uh,
and like having a jump shot.
It's put me up to an eight
five I'm bang and tense.
I've always wanted to be
a cop at the parks here.
Seen better if I was able to make money
doing it. Other than the dancing thing,
I wouldn't just be getting Hummerus
for letting gross moms off on speeding
tickets. I could be bagging J
lo. She's into dancers. Right?
Thanks. Yeah, Dude. Apps
a Fuckin lutely dude.
You're basically saying,
what should I do here?
Okay.
Should I bang j Lo's beat down at the
club and make all this fucking money or
should I take a job where I'm going
to get shot at and not be appreciated?
Okay.
You know, I'll tell you every cop
out there with dance, if they could,
as opposed to being a cop, I don't care
if they had like seven generations.
Yeah.
Dude, this is what I think of as
far as like dancing. I think if I,
if I,
yeah,
like compare it to being a comedian.
Oh,
the open mics would be getting a piece
of cardboard and being on a subway
platform, making money that way. And then
yeah,
when you move up to hosting a show that
would be addressed as a cop and you
fucking dance at Bachelorette parties.
That's what you do on the side.
That's like you fucking day
job. That bullshit. And then
during the day, I, yeah,
I would try out for those. Fuck, I don't,
do they make music videos
anymore or fucking, uh,
I dunno. I believe it or not, I don't
know how to climb the ladder as a dancer.
But dude,
apps a Fuckin lutely if you
can make money doing that shit.
And then what the great thing is, is
once you get to a certain level to, to,
uh, make more money, you don't want,
you got some credibility. You can know,
you always have the fall back where
you can teach a class, they get,
you can be like I danced for nine years
and Chitty Chitty Bang Bang and fucking
banged every fucking broad on there.
And then you, if you'd like to not have,
fuck the women in your cast
while still not losing your job,
come on down to Frankie's
swapping, Dade Studio, whatever.
Just you'll figure it out as
you go in there. And um, yeah,
absolutely. Absolute fucking Luli. I
would definitely do it. You want to do it?
He wouldn't taken the
time, um, to write in.
So your big fears, she'll be whatever.
But everybody's big fear is like,
what if I fucking go after this dream
and I'm 30 and I'm sleeping on a Fuckin
futon and it hasn't happened yet.
Well I've got to tell you something sir.
I've been there.
I was there at fucking 34.
I was still sleeping on a
Futon in a fucking studio
apartment that they called a
one bedroom cause they slammed a fucking
wall in there and put a door on it.
And then one day I was trying to bang
the girl upstairs who had the fucking
apartment right above me,
and it was exact same unit
and hers was a studio,
but she had been there longer so
they never slammed a wall in there.
And I realized, Hey, wait a minute,
I'm getting fucked. You know,
I should go down there and try to
get some money taken off of this.
I should go down to the,
uh, they're fucking me over
rental board. But I didn't,
I said, fucking just keep writing
jokes, right. So whatever,
oh, you gotta do, you just got
to commit to this shit and uh,
and then realize that, you know,
sleep on the Futon when you're 30 is,
is not the worst thing. It
isn't. You don't see, you know,
it's worse than sleeping on futons at 30,
sleeping in a king bed next to a fuck
a woman you're not really love with,
but for some reason married and he got
a couple of kids and you've got a job
that you fucking hate.
Okay?
You'll be laying there fantasizing about
fucking sleeping on a, on a, on a, uh,
on a futon there.
There's no risk when you go after a dream,
it's all fucking reward.
It's all going to lead to something good.
It always does.
There's a tremendous amount of
risk to playing it safe and uh,
that leads to unbelievable
levels of regret,
which is something else.
I've also experienced it because I'm
an old mother fucker. Um, so that's it.
That's the podcast for this
week. Okay. If you want to dance,
if you want to get stamps,
I think I fucking covered everything.
If you want to know what somebody sounds
like after having eggs and then a big
slice of cheesecake, uh, that's
what I gave you this week. Um,
okay. So this week my little
vacation has ended. Alright.
And I am now on my way to,
uh, doing some more gigs here.
Oh wait, I felt, I forgot. Gamefly
I've got to hide. Gamefly this,
this one has been a monster
on this podcast and I'll
be the only one who doesn't
get on game fly. And I know
what you're thinking. But bill,
I don't like video games. You know what
I'm thinking? You're a fucking communists.
Get out of this country. You've
Pinko bastard. All right, lovely.
Nia just walks in on you. Pinko bastard,
look at you when you have pajamas.
Nia bought the cutest pair of pajamas.
They're absolutely adorable.
They make it look like a little kid who
needs somebody to make her breakfast yet
she wears them every day.
So the lust is wearing off and you got
to get self another couple of pairs.
All right? Okay. She's not in the
mood. Um, gang, fly.com everybody. Hey,
do you like video games?
Sure we all do. Um, you know,
it'd be awesome.
What if you could have 8,000 Giddyup
giddyup video games at your fingertips?
What if they brought
him right to your door?
What if they could send them right
to your PC? What have you got?
A 15 day free offer where you could just
use all your vacation time and just sit
there and growing a beard, trying
every video game, possibly known to,
man,
why don't you go to game fly.com?
Why are you still sitting at
your cubicle pretending to work?
This is what you need to do.
You need to wait until I find the email
that has all the information on it.
That's what you need to do,
but right now,
what you want you to repeat over
and over in your head is gamefly
Jesus Christ. Do I like
gamefly? What the hell is it?
Game flight.com over 8,000 console
game. No late fees, no late fees.
You can cancel anytime.
So it's not that Bronx tale where they
put the thing down. Now you can't leave.
You can leave whenever you want to. Um,
now they're introducing unlimited PC.
Play a Monday morning podcast listeners.
Get a 15 day free tarp free trial.
This is what you do.
You go to www dot [inaudible] dot com
slash burr to activate the special offer.
You see that? Who's
looking out for you? Now?
You know what you guys could do for me.
You could look out for me.
You want to watch me struggle
through a new hour of material.
It's not going to be a new hour. It's
going to be a new 10 minutes. And uh,
that's how I put together the new hour.
I dump 10 minutes of the last hour.
I do 50 minutes of the old hour
and 10 minutes in the new hour.
I don't want you saying right now.
Bill, why don't you shut the fuck up.
Tell me where you're going to
be. Well, I've got to tell you,
I'm going to be at the dupont theater.
White people say Du Pont black people say
dupont, like police the dupont theater.
Oh,
snap.
I'm going to be there with the teen
idol sensation from the opiate Anthony
Program. Joe Derosa, the triumphant return
to Wilmington, Delaware by Joe Derosa.
He has not been there since
he dropped his last hit album.
Born to dance. That was a bad one.
I could've come with a bed. One
stranger in this town was at the
Bon Jovi one. Who gives a fuck.
I'll be at the dupont,
the at dupont theater March 30th
with the teen idol sensation.
Joe Smoking, Joe Derosa.
Um, go to bill bird.com.
Click on shows. The next, the next one.
I will be at the music hall in Troy,
New York on March 31st
with New Jersey's own.
Paul Versey loves the jets and the giants.
Whoever's doing better,
he will root for them.
And then the music hall in Tarrytown,
New York on April 1st. This is
not an April fool's joke. People.
I'm really going to be there.
Are you going to be there?
And I will also be there once again
with the wonderfully talented,
the freshly bearded Paul Versey.
You know, Paul Versey took my, uh,
personal trainer beard that I stole from
Bob on the biggest loser Paul verse.
He took it. He took it from me. You know,
as long as he doesn't steal my material.
I don't mind if he takes my facial hair.
Oh,
you're going to go to your little workout
class. All right. I'm almost done here.
All right. I'll be done in a second
if you just let me do it. Um,
um, oh, here's one for you.
You know something I was telling you what
really bothered me was when Davy Jones
died, just really fucking bothered
me. Just really made me feel old.
I'd love the monkeys. I thought they
were hilarious. And I love their music.
And you know what's funny is
I was reading all this shit,
the amount of crap that they
got because they were a prefab.
They called him the prefab for because
it was just a TV show and they were
basically, it was basically the
Beatles meets, meets the, uh,
the Marx brothers and all this
shit that they went through.
But I always find it funny when you
go on Youtube and every music thing,
you know, if you, if
you go, when you look up
something and some sort of
music that people respect it.
Like what happened to music and people
always trashing Justin Bieber going,
what happened to music? I wish I was
born back in the fucking day. Well,
here's something that I read. Do you
know what the height of the monkeys fame?
They sold more albums than the Beatles
and the rolling stones combined.
All right.
So it's always been that way.
There's always been some
fucking hottie going, oops.
At dd to again at played with your part,
right?
Yeah.
Shaking her fucking hips.
It's always going to be that,
okay,
Barry Manilow that song, Mandy, you blah,
and you bleed and you blue blue,
and I wanna fuck you.
Now,
Mandy,
right when Zeppelin was doing
what the fuck they were doing,
when a, when fucking black Sabbath
was at the height of their powers,
when they brought the devil
to their fucking knees, right?
Or to his knees or whatever the fuck it
is that there was people making fucking,
I'm Henry the eighth die Yam. It's,
it's always been like that. So please,
if you go on Youtube, can you please
stop writing what happened to music?
Nothing has happened to it.
All right? What's the matter?
Does it take work to find the good music?
You lazy costs. Go out and go find it.
All right, that's the podcast for
this week. Go fuck yourselves.
Don't take any shit. I'll talk to you
next week. And, uh, please keep up.
Please keep emailing the, uh,
the podcast because I can't,
I can't do this thing with
just me and cheesecake alone.
All right?
And I think that that's one to grow on.